so earlier this week just by virtue of
some clips we were looking at i ended up
talking a little bit about
areas where the right just crushes the
left on activism now i use the term
activism loosely because a lot of what
the right is doing is not really
activism it's sort of demonization
and uh it's it's really sort of a
different animal but to the extent that
the right is able to get
organized in certain ways they crush the
left and that includes at the local
level i've talked about
uh city councils i've talked about
funding the sort of training of young
conservatives as they come out of
college which the left barely does i've
talked about school boards and so on and
so forth
we now have an article that perfectly
illustrates this point
and it should really scare the left
because the left is terrible at this
type of stuff
and it's allowing the right to just do
it and to win
on a lot of these increasingly cultural
issues which is the the battle they've
chosen to fight
understand that the right has abandoned
fighting on policy they're fighting
cultural issues uh and this is a perfect
example take a look at this
article and truth out right wingers are
taking over
library boards to remove books on racism
now we hear this and we go oh my god
this is so retrograde this is so
backwards we could be that this this
energy
that's been being spent on this could be
spent on
a thousand things that are uh more
valuable and i'm with you
but the point is they're not doing it
and we're not fighting them
as as efficiently and as uh
um uh intelligently as we could listen
to what the article says
um when joe mccoola decided to run for
the board of the niles
maine public library in niles illinois
this spring a community member asked him
how he thought the library could better
serve the area's increasingly diverse
community
many were stunned by his response
instead of stocking up on books in seven
different languages he said
if we got people to assimilate and learn
english that would do more good that's
not policy that's a cultural issue
at the time of his candidacy makula was
a known person in niles having
previously led efforts to impose term
limits
on elected officials and stopped the
town mayor from filling vacant trustee
positions but his interest in the
library
was new elizabeth lynch a member of the
save niles library coalition says she
doesn't know what provoked mccool's
involvement but it became apparent his
goal
was to object to the library being a
community center
he also opposed to spending their
spending to repair the building's aging
roof
and upgrade the facility to better
bridge the digital divide
separating low-income residents from
their more affluent neighbors
but despite or perhaps because of his
political outlook makula
won the april election and now holds a
seat on the library board
it goes on to say since they're swearing
in on may 19th the new board has wasted
no time in imposing its agenda
their focus is to change the very nature
of the library they've slashed the
budget from 7.4 to 5.9 million
fired staff for reduced hours gone from
70 hours a week to 54 of being open
eliminated outreach to schools and
nursing homes and
and and they are starting to
uh actually weigh in on what books
should be allowed some locales are
making opposition to critical race
theory their core focus
but other locations are adding virulent
opposition to comprehensive
sex education lgbtqia plus acceptance in
a trio of concerns
they are fighting this from the ground
up
now is it disgusting of course it is
is it retrograde is it the stuff of
let's go back to the 50s and that these
right-wingers dream of
it's all of that and i'm against all of
it but much like i think
mitch mcconnell's actions have been
disgusting
can anyone say mitch mcconnell hasn't
been a hugely
effective republican from the standpoint
of
uh pushing the right agenda and blocking
the democratic agenda absolutely and so
unless we are going to get down and
fight them in these areas
we're just going to keep losing on a lot
of this stuff and we can go back to some
of the clips i played for you
earlier this week here's the clip of uh
from cpac
uh this was an interview with a couple
people at cpac remember this is the
stuff i pointed out and i said
they are smart to fight at this level
pay attention to their children and what
they say when they come home from school
don't criticize listen if there's things
that go against what they've been
teaching their children
then they need to go to a school board
meeting and they do
and they do is what we're learning need
to read the books that our kids are
being forced to read
so that we can have an honest
conversation with them there's a way to
fight back
and the way to do it is use your words
and use your money
go to your schools don't send your kid
to an indoctrination camp
and they're doing it okay here's another
one this was just a random interview i
mean
as far as we know sometimes these are
plants but as far as we know this was a
random interview at cpac
um uh uh and listen right away to what
this woman i believe from california
says
sure sure what are you yeah i am from
california
and um i'm an activist and uh i believe
in what we're saying here about getting
involved and stuff
but i think we forget to mention that
how we're going to do that we need to
get back into the neighborhoods
we need to do in california right now we
are organizing
uh precincts and voter registration
we're not talking about voter
registration i i think that's
actually that's a great point i'm glad
you came up to us these people
understand it now am i saying the left
doesn't understand it no
i think the left probably does
understand it i think the left probably
does understand it but
they're crushing us on this stuff and so
i am restating
the school boards the library boards i
mean listen when you
think of a library this is so micro but
politics is local think of a library
the very people that conserve i'll i'll
give you
even a specific example um you walk
around
on a small town's main street and you
see
uh people uh panhandling asking for
money
and uh the conservatives say this looks
terrible and this affects property
values and many on the left say the same
thing
great okay well let's get these folks
jobs uh many of them don't have internet
access many of them
uh uh you would need internet access in
order to get a job so where can you go
and get internet access well
you can go to libraries i have a friend
who's a librarian who says we have lots
of folks that come in and they're
what they're doing on our computers with
free internet access is applying
to jobs so being able to do that would
get folks
off of the street which is what
conservatives claim to want
and it wouldn't get them off because of
welfare it would get them off because
they got a job great
but then the conservatives go in and
they say let's slash the library budgets
and let's make the computer room smaller
or eliminate them all together or not
replace the computers or whatever the
case may be
so not only are they beating us on a lot
of this stuff
by beating us on it they continue to
perpetuate
their talking point which is look at all
this terrible stuff going on in the
panhandling and the democratic mayor
well it's not the democratic mayor maybe
it's that conservative library board
that is making it so that a lot of these
folks don't have a place to go and apply
for jobs it's a micro
example but it illustrates exactly what
we're up against
and um it's just you know that just
dropped right in after the conversation
we had on monday so let's
we've got to refocus on that and we'll
have more to say about it in the future
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40
off and free shipping when you go to
4sigmatic.com pacman
the link is right underneath this video